what's that believe nation I made the
did you know series you try to learn a
little bit more about some of our famous
entrepreneurs and maybe introduce you to
some a few surprising facts and might
find interesting
so today we're gonna learn 9 surprising
facts about Kanye West
[Music]
number one Michael Jackson told Kanye he
could sing what about Michael you talk
about Michael all the time you did a
remix for him
did you ever any ever have an MJ
personal encounter yeah i sat with
Michael Jackson
I met him over Leo Cohen's house and I
just vibe down with him and then like I
think Michael would want to put that
battery in my back to do 808 I played a
good life and he was like who's that
singing right there I like that voice it
was my voice he gas me up next thing
y'all know y'all have me in the night I
like Michael Jackson told me I could
sing [ __ ] all y'all you know fact number
two Tanya originally went to art school
but dropped out so he can do music
originally I went to art school I had
scholarships at a placement in Mars
because anybody thought I was gonna be
an artist what did you do somebody just
pieces right here that calm 94-95 like
okay what's this you got a blue ribbon
on this one that's because I want anime
in Japanese art this one is kind of
eerie it was a good exercise that the
teacher gave us and it's not very good
but since there was a dude looking like
he was dead I just put my name on them
put 1977 to 1995 which is the year which
I actually drew it and somebody should
have killed me for how bad this actually
was but but this is almost like a
premonition of a sort of because you
know you were like this at the end of
your car accident you were in the bed
like this thing you thought was your
deathbed right so I would never drop
myself dead ever again you ever find
time to do this anymore sad only now
trying I just use that as a language
like I want it to look like this
I love is wrong bodies love music more
see my thing
think about the drawings is I couldn't
turn them up loud enough I wanted to do
something where people have it on all
the time and basically now what my music
is is a soundtrack to millions of
people's lives you couldn't get that
feeling from article I couldn't get it
number three before writing his own
music he produced music for other stars
like jay-z so I used to just take the
New Jersey Transit and I'd pack up all
my stuff pack up all my debts and put
them in a bag and just walk over here to
baseline and that was the key right
there being able to walk up in the bass
line and play these rappers these beats
and I remember his beanie sigel whose
birthday I came and I played a bunch of
like soul beats like we have so beats
here in there well I had a bunch that I
was building up like just like the front
of success can't be life I was like I
need to make some more stuff in this van
right here so I'm playing baby some BC
to get to smile like yeah it's like you
know say but you had to go somewhere I
know he's been going somewhere for his
birthday
so that hole came in I'm gonna be had a
Gucci hat on like the fisherman joint
and hip-hop my manager who definitely
saved my life was like go play that one
beat for pho then it came on he was this
tool like oh it's crazy right here then
I got to the course and of course it's
like ain't no love and the heart of the
city is like Oh Dada Dada
he's like a play next to beat playing
next beat I played another beat it's
just short like yo man you were soulful
do and everything that whole verse
saying is like installing that I would
never forget none of these words cuz I'm
off the train I'm from Chicago
I got ten dollars in my pocket right now
and I'm just having an opportunity to
play these beats so I'm you know say
I've had different so-called hit records
that everything up to that that point
but at this point it's like I'm just
this is like the moment of truth for me
right here so now I play another beat
don't play another B then I played this
one beat it was like
never never never never changed I never
changed yo he took his hat days ago I
like uh maybe you like him maybe hold my
body's B so um he was like yo put them
Joyce on CD and then he left out right
okay okay I'm putting these noises CD
you see what happen so then um two weeks
later the blueprint was finished right
so um basically at that point everything
started rolling
everybody's like yo man I heard you had
the half of the blueprint out I heard
you did half of jay-z's out I couldn't
even believe it myself now cuz the
hip-hop G the blueprint and then I'm
over here with the opportunity to get my
music out which is what I want it's just
third grade Jonesy
in 2002 he survived the near fatal car
crash which pumped him to right through
the wire when I had my accident I found
out at that moment nothing in life is
promises chef des if you had the
opportunity to play this game of life
you need to appreciate every moment a
lot of people don't appreciate their
moment until it's past
and then you gotta tell those our Bundy
stories you remember when I but um right
now it's my time and my moment thanks to
the fans thanks to the accident thanks
to God thanks to Rockefeller jay-z Dame
Dash G my mother Rhymefest everyone
that's helped me and I plan I plan to
celebrate
I plan to celebrate and scream and pop
champagne every chance I get
because I'm not the Grammys Baby Talk
number five he announced in 2020 that is
going to run for president as you
probably could have guessed by this
moment I have decided in 2020 to run for
president I was actually watching I saw
him do it and I said that's very
interesting I wonder who gave him that
idea Miley Cyrus said oh I was gonna
vote for Trump but now I'm voting for
you so it sounded like she was all made
up for me and he took her away he's
actually a different kind of a person
than people think he's a nice guy doc
number six he has an amazing work ethic
and completely immerses himself in his
projects I got to watch Kanye make some
of the last record not the Twisted
Fantasy record yeah the Twisted Fantasy
record man and you know he lived it he
was living it like when you say he lived
it like was he literally in the stoop
like a mad scientist man was in the
studio kind of every day but the student
first of all I hope he doesn't you know
you know Kanye get mad at you then you
get just on a record I was impressed
like first of all everybody in this
studio had suits on everybody kidding me
I'm serious
was it like a prereq yo I thought he'd
like flown in a bunch of guys from like
Europe or something but like all the all
the engineers and everybody was in like
black suits and white white shirts and
black like he set up a mood right yeah
when you walked in there you felt this
mood when you wouldn't especially like
when you win an Electric Ladyland you
felt like yes interest it was yeah he's
that a mood man and you know and you
knew he was gonna be there was I stopped
in a few nights yeah and we did um what
did we do we did the blame game we did
the blame game yeah you know when you
talk to him he's living it
he's immersed in it he's immersed in and
when he does the fashion he's a murse
didn't ya fact number seven Kanye
suggested that John Stephens change his
name to John Legend used to be John
Stephens yeah it was Kanye West who said
change to legend you know the first
person actually was a guy named Jay IV
who's also from Chicago and his a friend
of mine and Kanye's and he's a poet
and we working on Kanye's album and
Kanye was having me seeing all these
parts and JAV was just like man we're
gonna have to call you the legend cuz
you know my voice is kind of old-school
I've always had an old soul and he he
just felt like that name was appropriate
for have you always known you always had
an old soul always know I had so when I
was when I was like seven or eight years
old my Halloween costume was I was
dressed up as a businessman with a with
a briefcase because I want I wanted to
be grown when I was like seven I liked
how my grandfather carried himself like
I just wanted to be grown even when I
was a little kid and then Connie is I
mean you should just call yourself John
Legend and I was like no that's
ridiculous and you know maybe I'll just
roll with this whole John Legend thing
fact number eight he filters his ideas
by speaking with thought leaders like
Elon Musk and Phil Knight his difference
between somebody who working for
somebody else's idea and a person who
made the idea because me and Phil Knight
gonna talk like this the way me and Elon
Musk talked for three hours like this
the way me and Eric Schmidt talk like
this but who are the people you just
named Elon Musk as the car company tests
the house has SpaceX also invented the
Hyperloop Eric Smith is the head of
Google got it so I'm just saying like
current civilization living civilization
that can actually have a full
conversation with what it is I'm
attempted to do so it's a lot of my
ideas that I put out in the world have
now then been pilfered through by you
know corporations whether there's sonic
ideas because Jesus at than a day you
can like you cannot like it but it's a
group of new ideas
doc number nine he's won 21 Grammy
Awards making him one of the most
awarded artists of all time I like to
thank everybody to accept it you know me
trying to break you know new boundaries
of music I wake up in the morning just
think about what stereotypes I want to
break and you know we push the envelope
with the last album with stronger
records that they thought wouldn't play
on urban radio and it's a it's our
responsibility as musicians to keep
pushing each other and keep competing
with each other it's a really great
competition I see artists like Beyonce
Alicia Keys Rihanna Chris Brown Chris
Martin all in the same room and we're
gonna push this music to the point where
it was like in the 60s and the 70s when
you talk about Led Zeppelin and Hendrix
and the Beatles we will be the new
Beatles the new Hendrix they say in any
other industry you know you're supposed
to do better than the past you know like
the computer should get smaller and
faster but whenever you say I want to be
Elvis they said what's wrong with you
but I want to be Elvis everybody asks me
the question they want to know what kind
I knew he's gonna roll out and he's
gonna do something crazy everybody
wanted to know what I would do if I
didn't win
I guess we'll never know
thank you guys so much for watching this
video love to know what did you think
let me know leave it down the comments
below what was your favorite surprising
fact how many of them actually surprised
you are the more that you want to add to
the list leave it down in the comments
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon
bonus fact number 10 Walt Disney is one
of his idols
I'm standing up and I'm telling you I am
Warhol I am the number one most
impactful artist of our generation
I am Shakespeare in the flesh what
Disney I mean taste culture art you know
just the quality of life now this is
this is what I'm here to do so when I
compare myself to Steve Jobs or Walt
Disney Howard Hughes David Stern
Michelangelo da Vinci Jesus or whatever
is I'm saying these are my heroes these
are people that I look up to this is the
type of impact I want to make on the
earth if I can make this type of impact
up to this point what can I do if if you
called Bob Iger and say yo give him a
shot if you call Oprah and say yo back
this kid let's just see this kid this
kids kids were his parents were
educators he wants to educate he wants
to look at curriculums and say how do we
simplify that exactly what I did in
music I want to apply to product I want
to apply to education this is what my
company donned is about it